How exactly would 3D printers
build a habitaton Mars?
If we leverage autonomous robotics,
we'll send 3D printers and other
constructionrobots
to build protective habitats and shelters
before the crew even arrives.
These structuresare manufactured
layer by layer by layer.
And as construction progresses, prebuilt and
preintegrated hardware like airlocks
or life support equipment brought from Earth
areinserted into the print until finally
they're sealed at various connection points.
We alsowant to incorporate practical
architectural elements such as
access to naturallight through windows and greenery.
Which we know are critical to positive
psychological functioning and well-being.